Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. You've been dating this great person for a while now. The hours you spend together feel like mere minutes. You're constantly texting, sharing photos, sending sappy kiss-face emojis. And then suddenly, he stops answering your text. Your calls go right to her voicemail. and they ignore your DMs. What happened? You've been ghosted. It's a heartbreaking fact in the modern dating world. Sometimes people are left just hanging without any explanation. And for those of you who have been ghosted, not only does it shatter your self-esteem, it can also hurt as much as physical pain. And to those of you out there who've done the ghosting, and I know they're out there, what's up with you? Okay, no shaming here. We're going to get to that soon with our guest today, psychologist Dr. Janice Philhauer.
你好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢娜。你和某人约会了一段时间，感觉非常棒。你们在一起度过的时光仿佛转瞬即逝。你们不断地发短信、分享照片、发送肉麻的亲吻表情包。然后突然间，他不再回复你的短信了。你的电话直接转入语音信箱，他们无视你的私信。发生了什么？你被“玩失踪”（ghosted）了。这是现代约会世界中一个令人心碎的事实。有时人们就这样被晾在一边，没有任何解释。对于那些被“玩失踪”的人来说，这不仅会摧毁你的自尊心，甚至可能像身体疼痛一样令人痛苦。而对于那些曾经“玩失踪”的人——我知道你们就在那里——你们是怎么想的？好吧，这里不进行道德审判。我们很快会和今天的嘉宾，心理学家珍妮丝·菲尔豪尔博士一起探讨这个问题。
She's the author of the popular psychology today articles, Why Ghosting Hurt So Much, and Did the Internet Break Love? She's here to help us understand why people do this and what you should do if you've been ghosted. Welcome, Dr. Villhauer. Hi, thank you so much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. Same here. We're happy to have you on the show discussing this very, very important topic.
她是《今日心理学》热门文章《为什么“玩失踪”会如此伤人》和《互联网摧毁了爱情吗？》的作者。她今天来到这里，是为了帮助我们理解为什么人们会这样做，以及如果你被“玩失踪”了该怎么办。欢迎你，维尔豪尔博士。你好，非常感谢邀请我。很高兴能来到这里。我也是。我们很高兴你能来到节目中讨论这个非常、非常重要的话题。
In your article, Why Ghosting Hurt So Much, you quoted someone who said they consider themselves to be an honest and straightforward person, yet they had ghosted someone. So I'm curious what would cause in a self-described honest individual to ghost? Right. Well, I think that we all engage in a level of sort of self-justification for our behavior. And, you know, we all know why we do what we do in a way that no one else can ever know that because we have all of our thoughts in our head and all of our kind of reasons lined up for why we make certain choices. So most people in their own mind sort of believe that they're doing the thing that is best for them. And oftentimes they're not really thinking about the impact that that has on another person.
在你的文章《为什么“玩失踪”会如此伤人》中，你引用了一个人的话，他说自己认为是一个诚实且直率的人，但他也曾对别人“玩失踪”。所以我很好奇，是什么原因会导致一个自称诚实的人去“玩失踪”呢？对。嗯，我认为我们所有人都会对自己的行为进行某种程度的自我辩解。而且，你知道，我们都知道自己为什么做我们所做的事，这种方式是别人永远无法了解的，因为我们脑子里有所有的想法，也有我们做出某些选择的所有理由。所以大多数人在自己的内心深处，往往认为自己正在做对自己最有利的事情。而很多时候，他们并没有真正考虑到这对另一个人产生的影响。
So what inspired you to write that article for psychology today? You know, I like to write articles that I think are going to be of value to people that I work with. And I know that within a very short period of time, I think I wrote the article back in 2015. I had three different patients that had all been ghosted by somebody. And it was just really, one, kind of remarkable to see that this was becoming such a common behavior. But two, it was very evident that it was also very, very painful and that people really didn't know how to deal with it. And so I wanted to personally understand it more. But also, I wanted to be able to kind of offer something to people who were going through this really difficult situation.
那么，是什么启发你为《今日心理学》撰写那篇文章的呢？你知道，我喜欢写一些我认为对我共事的人有价值的文章。我知道在很短的时间内——我想我是在2015年写的这篇文章——我有三位不同的病人，他们都被人“玩失踪”过。这真的非常引人注目，一方面，看到这正成为一种如此普遍的行为；但另一方面，很明显这也非常、非常痛苦，而且人们真的不知道该如何应对。所以我个人想更多地了解它。同时，我也希望能为那些正在经历这种非常困难处境的人提供一些帮助。
Can you explain how being ghosted can activate the same pathways in your brain as physical pain? Yes. So pain, physical pain and emotional pain are actually on the same neuro pathway. And so they've done a lot of research that shows that social rejection can cause the same level of pain that sort of an injury to your body would cause. And it's sort of activated in the same region of the brain. And it's sort of activated in the same region of the brain. brain. And so they've done studies that show people can take Tylenol that will actually help alleviate emotional pain. So that's actually something that, you know, someone can do if they're really in a kind of acute state of emotional pain, that that helps a little bit. That's fascinating that there's that connection because you wouldn't think. I mean, I would never think in a million years that Tylenol could help you feel better if you were experiencing some kind of emotional pain. Well, I think it explains why so many times people,
你能解释一下为什么被“玩失踪”会激活大脑中与身体疼痛相同的通路吗？是的。所以，身体疼痛和情感痛苦实际上是在同一个神经通路上。因此，他们做了很多研究，表明社会排斥会导致与身体受伤相同程度的疼痛。它是在大脑的同一区域被激活的。而且它是在大脑的同一区域被激活的。所以他们做了研究，表明人们服用泰诺（Tylenol）实际上有助于缓解情感痛苦。所以，如果有人真的处于一种急性情感痛苦状态，这确实是他们可以做的事情，这会有所帮助。这太令人着迷了，竟然有这种联系，因为你根本想不到。我的意思是，我做梦也想不到如果你正在经历某种情感痛苦，泰诺能让你感觉好受些。嗯，我认为这解释了为什么很多时候人们，
people try to numb themselves when they're feeling emotional pain. You know, they'll drink alcohol or take, you know, other kind of drugs or medications that really try to help, you know, kind of just numb the actual part of the brain that's creating what feels like the emotional distress. You spoke just a few minutes ago about how people ghost because they know in their heads why they're justifying their behaviors. But specifically to romantic relationships, why do you think we see ghosting happening? so often in the dating world? Well, I think it's something that has always occurred throughout time,
人们在感到情感痛苦时会试图麻痹自己。你知道，他们会喝酒，或者服用其他种类的药物或药剂，试图帮助麻痹大脑中产生这种情感困扰的部分。你几分钟前谈到人们之所以“玩失踪”，是因为他们在脑海中知道自己为什么要为自己的行为辩解。但具体到浪漫关系，你认为为什么我们在约会世界中如此频繁地看到“玩失踪”现象？嗯，我认为这在历史上一直存在，
but just maybe not on the scale that it's happening now. I think part of that has to do with, you know, a very big cultural shift that has happened in dating, you know, particularly the internet, I think, has been one source of that, that big shift that has been happening. And that doesn't mean I think that the internet is bad or somehow, you know, been a negative thing for love. But I do think that it's like anything, there's good and there's bad. And I think one of the consequences is that people are a bit more indifferent to one another. And I think that it, when you meet somebody online, there's less social accountability because you're oftentimes meeting people that are not in your social circle that don't know other people. And it just becomes much easier to move on from a relationship very
只是可能没有现在发生的规模这么大。我认为部分原因与约会中发生的巨大文化转变有关，你知道，特别是互联网，我认为这是那个巨大转变的来源之一。这并不意味着我认为互联网是坏的，或者对爱情来说是负面的。但我确实认为，就像任何事物一样，它有好的一面，也有坏的一面。我认为后果之一是人们对彼此更加冷漠了。而且我认为，当你在网上遇到某人时，社会问责制会减少，因为你经常遇到的人不在你的社交圈内，也不认识其他人。当你的社交圈里没有其他人会反对你对待别人的方式时，从一段关系中走出来就变得容易多了，
quickly when you don't have anybody else in your social circle that is going to, you know, object to the way that you're treating somebody else. And that's what you think might be different from the past. Like, I mean, kind of imagining, like, you know, the past, if even before cell phones, if you gave your phone number to someone, you went on a few dates and it didn't work out, you could probably screen their calls or something when you had the, you know, voicemail. recorder. So that was probably still happening, I imagine, but as you're saying, with the internet's made people more distant or there's just not those mutual connections that might cause a person to under, you know, societal pressure, at least acknowledged a person and say, you know, I'm not
而且速度非常快。这就是你认为可能与过去不同的地方。我的意思是，想象一下过去，即使在手机出现之前，如果你把电话号码给某人，你们约会了几次但没成，你可能还是会筛选他们的电话，或者当你有语音留言录音机时做些什么。我想那可能还是会发生，但正如你所说，互联网使人们更加疏远，或者只是没有那些可能会导致一个人在社会压力下，至少承认对方并说“我不感兴趣”的共同联系。
interested. You know, let's move on with our lives. Sure. Well, I think it's a number of factors. I mean, number one, there's the quantity of people that we now have access to, right? So it's very easy to kind of look at a page of potential dating, you know, mates and sort of see that there's as many, many, many people out there to me. And so it makes the ideal seem more possible and the pursuit of that kind of ideal relationship. And I think people have in a lot of ways developed what's called the consumerism mindset around dating where it's kind of, you sort of believe you can shop for somebody. You can just find the next person if the current relationship doesn't seem to kind of meet your ideal set of standards. And I think that people start to lose their own
你知道，让我们继续各自的生活吧。当然。嗯，我认为这是多种因素共同作用的结果。首先，我们现在可以接触到的人数非常多，对吧？所以很容易浏览一页潜在的约会对象，并看到外面有很多人。这使得理想显得更有可能实现，也使得对那种理想关系的追求变得更加强烈。我认为人们在很多方面围绕约会发展出了一种所谓的“消费主义心态”，即你认为你可以像购物一样挑选某人。如果当前的关系似乎不符合你理想的标准，你就可以找到下一个人。而且我认为人们开始失去对自己为什么一段关系可能不奏效的责任感。他们并没有真正意识到一段关系可能不奏效是因为他们个人所做的事情。所以我认为这里有不同的因素在起作用。
accountability for why a relationship might not be working. They don't really realize that a relationship might not be working out because of things that they personally are doing. So I think that there's different factors that play out there. Yeah, and that's, you talked a lot about that in your article, did the internet break love, which, by the way, the title is just really spot on and very good. There's obviously some factors that are lost through the apps. Like the number one, there's the abundance of people, you know, the indifference you might see, the lack of mutual connections that connect you with other people longer than just an initial date or something like that. But what else is lost
是的，你在文章《互联网摧毁了爱情吗？》中谈到了很多这一点，顺便说一句，这个标题真的很贴切，非常好。通过应用程序，显然失去了一些因素。比如第一，人们的数量非常多，你知道，你可能会看到的冷漠，缺乏将你与他人联系起来的共同联系，而不仅仅是最初的约会之类。但还有什么通过互联网约会应用程序丢失了呢？
through internet dating apps? I mean, a lot of people are on them today. I've certainly met a lot of people who have found their significant other through online dating apps. But what is missing today that might have been different in the past? Well, like I said, I don't think that it's all good or all bad. I think that, you know, like you said, I know lots of people who have also met their significant others. So I think there is a lot of, you know, value in the ability to meet people that are outside your social circles and to have, you know, just greater access to potential partners. But I think that what happens is over time, the more sort of choice you have, the more people start to lose their own value in some way. So when you only have, you know, two or three people
今天很多人都在使用它们。我当然遇到过很多通过在线约会应用程序找到另一半的人。但今天缺失了什么，而过去可能有所不同呢？嗯，就像我说的，我不认为这全是好或全是坏。我认为，就像你说的，我也认识很多通过在线约会找到另一半的人。所以我认为，能够结识社交圈之外的人并获得更多潜在伴侣的机会，确实有很多价值。但我认为发生的情况是，随着时间的推移，你拥有的选择越多，人们开始在某种程度上失去自己的价值。所以当你只有两三个人可以选择时，
to choose from, there's greater value that each one of those people are going to have. But when you've got hundreds of people to choose from, people almost in some ways lose their value because you can always find the next person if, you know, this one particular person isn't sort of satisfying or gratifying all the sort of ideals that you have for a relationship. So there's a level of indifference that I think occurs. You know, when 100 people are emailing you, you can't possibly respond to all of those people. And you just start to develop a level of, I guess, indifference is the best word that I have to really describe that. Yeah. How can you fight back against that indifference? I mean, obviously, you said you're not going to respond to those 100 messages. But are there are there
这每个人都会有更大的价值。但当你有一百个人可以选择时，人们在某种程度上几乎失去了他们的价值，因为如果这个特定的人不能满足你对关系的所有理想，你总能找到下一个人。所以我觉得存在一种冷漠。你知道，当一百个人给你发邮件时，你不可能回复所有这些人。你只是开始产生一种冷漠，我想这是我能用来真正描述它的最好的词。是的。你如何对抗那种冷漠？我的意思是，显然，你说你不会回复那一百条信息。但有没有什么
tips that you might offer someone, you know, who is using online dating and a way, in ways to stay more engaged in the experience and have a better outcome for themselves and, you know, hopefully they meet a mate? Well, I think the problem is broader than just social dating apps. I think, you know, there's been a loss of, I think, sort of overall general empathy for people. And that's one of the things that happens, I think, as a consequence of social media in general that, you know, there's people just feel that they can kind of speak to people any way that they want to, that they can, you know, treat people in a just much more indifferent sort of way. And so, you know, how do you counter that?
建议可以提供给那些正在使用在线约会的人，让他们在体验中保持更多的参与感，并为自己获得更好的结果，希望他们能遇到伴侣？嗯，我认为这个问题比单纯的社交约会应用程序更广泛。我认为，你知道，人们对人的整体同理心已经丧失了。我认为这是社交媒体带来的后果之一，人们只是觉得他们可以以任何他们想要的方式与人交谈，他们可以以一种更加冷漠的方式对待他人。所以，你知道，你如何反击呢？
I think you have to make a deliberate sort of intention to really want to kind of think about the other person's feelings, to really care about the other person's feelings. And the reality is, you know, of the people who have been. ghosted, 50% of those have actually also ghosted other people. So I think what happens is that once you've experienced it yourself, you also become sort of indifferent to it. And people are just starting to kind of shut down emotionally around sort of how they treat others in a dating environment. And I think you have to really make the deliberate effort to say, I want to be kind and respectful to somebody. And, you know, it doesn't have to require a huge amount of effort. You can
我认为你必须做出深思熟虑的意图，真正想要去考虑对方的感受，真正关心对方的感受。事实是，你知道，在那些被“玩失踪”的人中，50%的人实际上也曾对别人“玩失踪”。所以我认为发生的情况是，一旦你自己经历过，你也会对它变得冷漠。人们开始在约会环境中对待他人的方式上在情感上变得麻木。我认为你必须真正做出深思熟虑的努力，说：“我想对某人友善和尊重。”而且，你知道，这不需要付出巨大的努力。你可以
send somebody, even just one sentence that says, you know, hey, it was great to meet you, but I don't think that this is going anywhere or I don't see this, you know, really being a connection, is profoundly helpful to somebody on the other end of the situation because it allows them to understand what was going on, like what happens, right? Because when you ghost somebody, you literally have absolutely no idea what happened to them. They could be lying in a hospital bed for all know, you have no way of knowing how to respond. So I think that intentional effort to think about the other person and to just try to be kind and to just, you know, think about how would you want to be treated in that situation? Yeah, I think that's what is probably the worst part is when you don't
给某人发一条信息，哪怕只有一句话，说：“嘿，很高兴见到你，但我认为这不会有结果，或者我没看到这真的能成为一种联系。”这对处于情况另一端的人来说是非常有帮助的，因为它让他们能够理解发生了什么，对吧？因为当你对某人“玩失踪”时，你真的完全不知道他们发生了什么。他们可能躺在医院的病床上，你根本无法知道该如何回应。所以我认为那种去考虑对方的深思熟虑的努力，只是试着友善一点，只是，你知道，想想如果你处于那种情况，你希望被如何对待？是的，我想这可能是最糟糕的部分，当你没有任何解释，
have any explanation and you're just left hanging, you don't know what the situation could be. Did something bad happen to the person? Did they just lose interest? I mean, that hurts if you don't, you're just left hanging without any explanation. You spend a lot of time kind of ruminating on. why that might happen. I mean, you know you can't get into specifics, but your clients were going through this, were they, what kind of feelings were they left with when this happened to them? Yes. So disposable, used, really terrified of having this happen to them again. A lot of times they'll spend hours trying to figure out what it is that they did wrong. And so, you know, it's a very, very painful experience for people to go through. Oftentimes, there's obviously
只是被晾在一边，你不知道情况会是什么。是那个人发生了什么坏事吗？还是他们只是失去了兴趣？我的意思是，如果你没有任何解释就被晾在一边，那真的很伤人。你会花很多时间去反思为什么会发生这种情况。我的意思是，你知道你不能谈论细节，但你的客户正在经历这些，当这种情况发生时，他们留下了什么样的感受？是的。感到被抛弃、被利用，非常害怕这种情况再次发生在自己身上。很多时候，他们会花几个小时试图弄清楚自己做错了什么。所以，你知道，这对人们来说是一种非常、非常痛苦的经历。很多时候，显然有
anger. And, you know, in my mind, that's actually one of the healthier responses to have is to kind of, you know, really understand that it really did not mean anything about, you know, the person who's been ghosted, but is really more of a reflection on the person who did the ghosting. So I think anger is probably a healthier response to the situation. But oftentimes it's just so impossible to understand how somebody could do that to them, that it's just very, very devastating. So how do you move on from that? I mean, what advice do you give to someone to help them move on from those feelings? And also, is there a way to protect yourself against this from happening in the future? You know, I wish I could say that there was. I think, you know, the best way to protect yourself is to, you know, really
愤怒。而且，在我看来，这实际上是更健康的反应之一，即真正理解这并不意味着被“玩失踪”的人有什么问题，而更多地反映了那个“玩失踪”的人。所以我认为愤怒可能是对这种情况更健康的反应。但很多时候，人们根本无法理解某人怎么能那样对待他们，这真的非常、非常令人崩溃。那么你如何从中走出来呢？我的意思是，你给那些帮助他们摆脱这些感受的人什么建议？另外，有没有办法保护自己免受未来这种情况的发生？你知道，我希望我能说有。我认为，你知道，保护自己最好的方法是，你知道，真正
be careful about who you're choosing, you know, to spend time with, look for those red flags, kind of early on in terms of, you know, how somebody treats you from, you know, the very initial kind of contact. But the truth is sometimes there just really is no way to know. And, you know, if it happens, you know, my advice is the first few sort of days is to do nothing because the instinct is to kind of want to, you know, find out immediately and to contact the person over and over. And that's really the worst thing to do. When somebody chooses to ghost you, that's a very very deliberate decision that they are making. You know, nobody kind of forgets to call you back when they're dating somebody. It's that they're choosing this behavior. They have made a decision
小心你选择花时间在一起的人，在早期阶段寻找那些危险信号，比如某人从最初的接触开始是如何对待你的。但事实是，有时真的没有办法知道。而且，你知道，如果它发生了，你知道，我的建议是前几天什么都不要做，因为本能是想要立即找出原因并一遍又一遍地联系那个人。而这真的是最糟糕的做法。当某人选择对你“玩失踪”时，这是一个非常、非常深思熟虑的决定。你知道，没有人会在约会时忘记给你回电话。这是因为他们选择了这种行为。他们已经做出了决定，
that they want to end the relationship. And whether you agree with the way that they're choosing to go about that or not, it's better for you to kind of take a step back and to kind of retain your own dignity and to really, you know, reach out to friends and to, you know, talk to people that you know really care about you and support you. But it feels really, really bad to be contacting someone and to continue to just get that silent treatment. It's, you know, the silent treatment is, you know, a very cruel thing to do for a specific reason is because it has such a very negative impact on, you know, the person who's on the receiving end of that. Kind of pivot's another question I had. So if you've been ghosted and you find yourself just obsessing about it and constantly being in touch
他们想要结束这段关系。无论你是否同意他们选择这样做的方式，退后一步并保持自己的尊严，真正地联系朋友，与那些你知道真正关心你并支持你的人交谈，这对你来说更好。但联系某人并继续得到那种冷处理的感觉真的很糟糕。你知道，冷处理是一种非常残忍的行为，原因很具体，因为它对处于接收端的人有非常负面的影响。这引出了我的另一个问题。所以如果你被“玩失踪”了，你发现自己只是对此念念不忘，并不断地联系
to that person and they're not responding, where does that? become problematic. I mean, and problematic, I mean, like, if you're, if you're just overdoing it and, you know, can you be turning to some kind of a stalker or something? I mean, that might be an extreme, but where can that go wrong where you just will not stop bothering someone who is clearly does not want to communicate with you? Sure. I think it's so hard. I mean, I think it's hard to know because you don't know what has happened to them. Like I said before, this person could be lying in a hospital bed somewhere, you know, something tragic could have happened. You you just don't know. So I think you can send one or, I think, one or two texts to, you know,
那个人，而他们没有回应，这在什么地方变得有问题了？我的意思是，所谓有问题，是指如果你做得太过分了，你知道，你是否会变成某种跟踪者之类的？我的意思是，那可能是极端的，但在什么地方会出错，你就是不停止打扰一个显然不想与你交流的人？当然。我认为这太难了。我的意思是，我认为很难知道，因为你不知道他们发生了什么。就像我之前说的，这个人可能躺在某个地方的医院病床上，你知道，可能发生了什么悲剧。你只是不知道。所以我认为你可以发一条或，我认为，一两条短信，
or try to reach out to the person, you know, maybe in a couple different ways once or twice to see if they're okay. I think, you know, it makes sense to want to check their social media just to see if they're posting or just that they're still alive or okay in some regard. But after that, you know, if you don't get a response after, you know, two sort of attempts to reach them, I think at that point you have to kind of take a step back and, you know, really realize that this person is making a deliberate choice. And by kind of continuing to try to contact them, you're not convincing them that somehow they made the wrong choice. You know, in some ways they themselves, regardless of whether this kind of makes sense, they may feel that you're disrespecting them by continuing to reach out to them, that you're not respecting the choice that they're making. making. And so it's better to really just kind of pull back and kind of, again, reach out to people
或者尝试通过几种不同的方式联系那个人，一两次，看看他们是否还好。我认为，你知道，查看他们的社交媒体看看他们是否在发帖，或者只是看看他们是否还活着或在某些方面还好，这是有道理的。但在那之后，你知道，如果你在两次尝试联系他们后没有得到回应，我认为在那一点上你必须退后一步，真正意识到这个人正在做出一个深思熟虑的选择。通过继续尝试联系他们，你并没有说服他们，他们以某种方式做出了错误的选择。你知道，在某种程度上，他们自己，无论这是否有意义，他们可能会觉得你通过继续联系他们而不尊重他们，你没有尊重他们正在做出的选择。所以最好还是退后一步，再次联系那些
who you know, care about you, your friends, your family, therapist, you know, whoever it is that can give you the comfort and support that you need while you're going through that and to help you try to process it in the best way that you can. But continuing to kind of reach the person or demand that they give you some sort of answer is generally not going to be the best thing to do. And is there a particular type of person who tends to ghost others? Do you ever you identified some traits? Well, you know, so many people ghost at this point. There was a study that was done, you know, right around the time that I actually had written the articles. This was a pretty old study at this point. It's about five years old. But it was saying that at almost 50% of people
你知道关心你的人，你的朋友、家人、治疗师，你知道，任何能给你提供你所需要的安慰和支持的人，当你经历这些时，并帮助你以你能做到的最好的方式处理它。但继续联系那个人或要求他们给你某种答案通常不会是最好的做法。有没有哪种特定类型的人倾向于对别人“玩失踪”？你有没有确定过一些特征？嗯，你知道，现在有太多人“玩失踪”了。有一项研究是在我写文章的时候做的，这在现在是一项相当古老的研究了。大约有五年了。但它说几乎50%的人
who are kind of in the dating world have either been ghosted or done ghosting. So, you know, it's, pretty common that this is happening. So I'm not sure there's a particular type of person. I think, you know, a lot of people who, you know, again, consider themselves to be really decent good people have perhaps ghosted somebody at some point. And oftentimes it's just the easier thing to do. You know, I think that it's just something that people do not, when they're just not thinking about how it's going to make somebody else feel. Another particular warning signs at all that you might be ghosted? Is it anything that you might look out for? Well, I think if somebody, you know, has a lot of contact with you and any time there's like a shift in, let's say, the general kind of pattern
在约会世界中，要么被“玩失踪”过，要么做过“玩失踪”的事。所以，你知道，这很常见。所以我不知道是否有特定类型的人。我认为，你知道，很多自认为是非常正派的好人的人，可能在某个时候也对别人“玩失踪”过。而且很多时候这只是更容易做的事情。你知道，我认为这只是人们在不考虑这会让别人感觉如何时所做的事情。有没有什么特别的警告信号表明你可能会被“玩失踪”？有什么你可以留意的吗？嗯，我认为如果某人与你有大量的接触，而任何时候如果接触和关系运作的总体模式发生了转变，
of how the contact and the relationship is working, right? So if somebody, you know, always text you first thing in the morning and suddenly you don't hear from them for, you know, a day or two, it obviously could be that there's just something else going on in their life. They're busy. They've got, you know, certain, you know, other priorities that they're taking care of. It doesn't necessarily mean they're going to ghost you. But if you start to notice, you know, a change in, you know, a normal kind of pattern of behavior, you know, it doesn't hurt to just kind of check in with the person and just say, hey, you know, kind of curious to see how things are going. You know, I've noticed, you know, it seems like there's been a shift. And so I think you can, you know, ask in that way. I think
对吧？所以如果某人总是第一时间给你发短信，突然间你有一两天没收到他们的消息，这显然可能是因为他们的生活中还有其他事情发生。他们很忙。他们有某些其他优先事项需要处理。这并不一定意味着他们要对你“玩失踪”。但如果你开始注意到正常行为模式的变化，你知道，去询问一下那个人并说：“嘿，你知道，很好奇事情进展如何。我注意到似乎发生了一些转变。”这并没有什么坏处。所以我认为你可以以那种方式询问。我认为
you know, a lot of times people who are going to ghost you aren't necessarily going to be really honest and open about their emotions in the first place. So, you know, it's hard to say if they're going to be really willing to tell you how they're really feeling. But, you know, I think that's really the most you can do is to just kind of notice and pay attention to, you know, the patterns in the relationship. But a lot of times there aren't going to be any warning signs. And I think that's one of the hardest parts. Definitely. And turning it more towards, and friendships, do you also see ghosting among friends? Yeah, you know, it's funny because when I wrote my article, I was very, in my mind,
你知道，很多时候那些要对你“玩失踪”的人，本身就不一定会对他们的情绪非常诚实和开放。所以，你知道，很难说他们是否真的愿意告诉你他们的真实感受。但是，你知道，我认为这真的是你能做的最多的事情，就是去注意并关注关系中的模式。但很多时候不会有任何警告信号。我认为这是最困难的部分之一。当然。转向友谊，你也会在朋友之间看到“玩失踪”吗？是的，你知道，这很有趣，因为当我写我的文章时，在我的脑海里，
it was very specific to dating because I think there's something about a dating relationship where when that, you know, just different level of emotion that gets involved and really different amount of pain that occurs when the ghosting happens. But, you know, I think, yes, I think it happens definitely in friendships. I think it's a broader, behavior that's about not feeling a level of comfort discussing your emotions with someone and choosing instead to just kind of disappear. And I'll be honest with you, you know, after I wrote my article, I got contacted by almost thousands, I would say literally, literally thousands of people who, you know, some of them were people who had ghosted. Some of them were people who, you know, had been ghosted.
它非常具体地针对约会，因为我认为约会关系中有些东西，当那种不同程度的情绪参与进来，当“玩失踪”发生时，确实会产生不同程度的痛苦。但是，你知道，我认为，是的，我认为它肯定发生在友谊中。我认为这是一种更广泛的行为，关于不觉得与某人讨论你的情绪很舒服，而选择直接消失。老实说，在我写完文章后，我几乎被成千上万的人联系过，我可以说真的是成千上万的人，其中一些人是曾经“玩失踪”过的人。其中一些人是曾经被“玩失踪”过的人。
But a lot of the people who had done the ghosting really felt very justified because they felt the other person wasn't going to listen to them or the other person wasn't maybe emotionally going to be able to handle it and they didn't want to have to deal with that. So it's a really, I think, very complicated situation where there's a lot of emotions on both sides in terms of, you know, whether this is considered appropriate or not. And I think you can't just kind of apply a blanket kind of statement across the board about what's okay and what's not. Right. And, you know, I imagine with friendships as well as the question I was talking about is, you know, how do you know the difference between simply drifting away from someone and ghosting? I think with romantic relationships, I could see that being a little different. Like I think that's a little bit more of like a definite point. But with friends, like you said, the relationship type is different. So perhaps with friendships, you might just simply drift away and you might not mean to not respond to the person, but you might just feel like the friendship just isn't working for you anymore.
但很多曾经“玩失踪”的人确实感到非常正当，因为他们觉得对方不会听他们说，或者对方可能在情感上无法处理，他们不想处理这些。所以我认为这是一个非常复杂的情况，双方在是否认为这合适的问题上有很多情绪。而且我认为你不能一概而论什么是可以的，什么是不可以的。对。而且，你知道，我想在友谊中也是一样，我刚才谈到的问题是，你知道，你如何区分仅仅是与某人渐行渐远和“玩失踪”？我认为在浪漫关系中，我可以看到那有点不同。就像我认为那更像是一个明确的点。但对于朋友，就像你说的，关系类型不同。所以也许在友谊中，你可能只是简单地渐行渐远，你可能并不是故意不回复那个人，但你可能只是觉得这段友谊不再适合你了。
I don't know what the reason might be. But can you do any thoughts about that? Yeah. Well, I feel like the same kind of rules apply in the sense that if a certain pattern of behavior exists, right, between people. Let's say you are used to speaking to your friend, you know, once a week. And suddenly you don't hear from them for a few weeks. You know, I think reaching out, you know, a couple times. I really think when you reach out more than twice, you're kind of pushing the boundary there, like sometimes, you know, but, you know, two, three times at the most. If the person's not responding to you, I think you have to just take a step back and let them see if they're going to come to, you know, kind of make the effort to respond or, you know, come back towards the relationship or just let them go if they're not willing to, you know? So I don't, I think it's it's the same idea. You can't force somebody to, who doesn't want to be in a relationship with you to continue a relationship with you. And you might not get to know why. And I know that
我不知道原因可能是什么。但你对此有什么想法吗？是的。嗯，我觉得同样的规则也适用，如果人与人之间存在某种行为模式的话。假设你习惯于每周和你的朋友交谈一次。突然间你有几周没收到他们的消息。你知道，我认为联系一两次。我真的认为当你联系超过两次时，你就在某种程度上越界了，有时，你知道，但，你知道，最多两三次。如果那个人没有回复你，我认为你必须退后一步，让他们看看他们是否会努力回复，或者回到这段关系中，或者如果他们不愿意，就让他们走，你知道吗？所以我认为这是同一个道理。你不能强迫一个不想和你建立关系的人继续和你建立关系。而且你可能无法知道原因。我知道这
sounds really painful and difficult, but you have to kind of give, like respect the choices that other people choose to make. Right. And to understand that if someone doesn't want to continue a relationship with you, that's better for you anyway, right? Like, you don't want to, you don't want to pursue relationships with people that aren't interested in maintaining those relationships or don't feel they value the relationship as much as you value the relationship. So sometimes you have to really reframe it and be willing to let the people that come into your life go if that's what they choose to do. So it sounds like it's a little bit more, can be a little more nuanced with friends. Is that what you're saying? Because like it might not be so hard and fast as it might be in a real life.
听起来真的很痛苦和困难，但你必须尊重其他人选择做出的选择。对。并且要明白，如果有人不想和你继续一段关系，这对你来说反正更好，对吧？就像，你不想追求那些对维持关系不感兴趣，或者觉得他们不认为这段关系像你认为的那样有价值的人的关系。所以有时你必须真正重新定义它，如果那是他们选择做的事情，就要愿意让进入你生活的人离开。所以听起来在朋友之间可能会更微妙一些。你是这个意思吗？因为就像它可能不像现实生活中那样硬性规定，
romantic relationship, but the overall message is the same. It's like if you've reached out, don't overdo it, but take a step back and say, okay, if they don't come to me and then it's time to let this go. But also, I want to talk about ghosting at the workplace because I had that actually happen in a work situation before where, you know, I got ghosted regarding a job. And it was just kind of odd, I thought, you know, I was just like, just no response at all. and I'm, you know, we moved on and, you know, with our lives. But, you know, we hear these stories of people who are working and then they all of a sudden, you know, leave for lunch and never come back. What are your thoughts about ghosting in the workplace?
浪漫关系，但总体信息是一样的。就像如果你已经联系过了，不要做得太过分，但要退后一步说：“好吧，如果他们不来找我，那么是时候放手了。”但我也想谈谈工作场所的“玩失踪”，因为我以前在工作情况中确实遇到过这种情况，你知道，我因为一份工作被“玩失踪”了。我觉得这很奇怪，你知道，我只是觉得，根本没有回应。然后我们继续各自的生活。但是，你知道，我们听到这些故事，人们在工作，然后他们突然间，你知道，去吃午饭就再也没有回来。你对工作场所的“玩失踪”有什么看法？
You mean somebody just quits and never tells anybody that they're kind of, yeah, doesn't show up, you know, obviously nothing to say that they're, you know, they're not injured or sick or anything, but just doesn't show up or leaves in the middle of the day, is doing an interview and, you know, is asked to take them to the next level. on the interview and just never responds? Well, I think that's more common than you may realize, but, you know, particularly when it, so, I mean, there's a lot of different scenarios there. But, you know, when you talk about interviews, I think it's actually very common to never hear back from somebody if they're not interested, you know, in hiring you that there's, people are so overwhelmed with, you know, I mean, obviously it's the polite thing to do. And it's a good company.
你是说有人辞职了却从来没告诉任何人他们，是的，不出现，你知道，显然没有任何迹象表明他们受伤或生病之类的，但就是不出现，或者在一天中间离开，正在面试，你知道，被要求进入面试的下一个阶段，却从来没有回应？嗯，我认为这比你意识到的要普遍得多，但是，你知道，特别是在，所以，我的意思是，那里有很多不同的场景。但是，你知道，当你谈论面试时，我认为如果他们对雇佣你不感兴趣，从来没有收到任何回音，这实际上是非常普遍的，你知道，人们被淹没了，你知道，我的意思是，显然这是礼貌的做法。而且这是一家好公司。
They know, you would hope that they would have an HR person. they'd be willing to at least send you a form letter. But oftentimes that's not the case. So you just never hear back if someone's not interested in hiring you. So I think that's actually fairly common. But in different scenarios, I mean, somebody's doing that professionally. It's not a good indication. It's not good for them, obviously, for, you know, for references or that type of thing.
他们知道，你希望他们会有一个人力资源人员。他们愿意至少给你发一封格式信。但很多时候情况并非如此。所以如果有人对雇佣你不感兴趣，你只是从来没有收到回音。所以我认为这实际上相当普遍。但在不同的场景中，我的意思是，有人在专业地做这件事。这不是一个好的迹象。这对他们来说显然是不好的，你知道，对于推荐信或这类事情。
But it's probably just an indication of just really, you know, something happening internally for them on emotion. level that they just don't feel capable of dealing with or being able to confront. So you're just thinking them along two different tracks, like someone who does the workplace might be. Do you think, do you look at them in different ways, or do you think it all comes down to the same behavior? I think at the end of the day, there's a similar thread that runs through in the sense that I think the people have different expectations about perceived obligations. within relationships, whether it's a dating relationship, whether it's a friendship, whether it's an interview work relationship, right? Just, you know, something very professional level.
但这可能只是表明，你知道，他们在情感层面上内部发生了某些事情，他们只是觉得没有能力处理或无法面对。所以你只是在两条不同的轨道上思考他们，比如在工作场所做这件事的人可能是。你认为，你以不同的方式看待他们，还是你认为这归根结底是相同的行为？我认为归根结底，有一条相似的线索贯穿其中，因为我认为人们对关系中感知的义务有不同的期望，无论是约会关系，无论是友谊，无论是面试工作关系，对吧？只是，你知道，非常专业层面的事情。
I think that, you know, oftentimes the person on the side where they're kind of doing the ghosting doesn't perceive they have an obligation to reach out to somebody, whereas the person who feels that they've been ghosted feels that there was an obligation. And, you know, I would like to say that there's some uniform standard for saying what's an appropriate obligation. You know, in my mind, common decency, being kind to other people, you know, it's just common courtesy to let somebody know if you're going to, you know, end somehow a contact. But, you know, I think a big kind of threat there is just a difference in expectations on both sides. And I think sometimes there's a bit of an avoidance factor as well, just a tendency to it's easier to avoid somebody and just ghost them than it is to
我认为，你知道，很多时候在“玩失踪”那一端的人并不认为他们有义务联系某人，而感到被“玩失踪”的人则认为有义务。而且，你知道，我想说有一个统一的标准来判断什么是适当的义务。在我看来，基本的体面，对他人友善，你知道，如果你要以某种方式结束联系，让某人知道这只是基本的礼貌。但是，你知道，我认为这里的一个大威胁只是双方期望的差异。而且我认为有时也存在一种回避因素，只是一种倾向，回避某人并直接对他们“玩失踪”比
kind of have the conversation that might be uncomfortable in some way about choosing to not want to be in a relationship with somebody because that's the other side of it. You know, it's very uncomfortable for a lot of people to have that conversation. And so that's why they choose ghosting instead. Is there where you can rise above those uncomfortable feelings and, you know, let someone know why you are ending the relationship, whether that's professionally, or I mean, whether that's a friendship, whether that's romantic. Yeah, well, I think it comes down to basic empathy, you know, really being able to step outside of yourself and put yourself into the other person's perspective. And just, you know, I always just say, you know, think in terms of, you know, how would you want to be treated
进行那种可能在某种程度上不舒服的关于选择不想与某人建立关系的对话要容易得多，因为那是它的另一面。你知道，对很多人来说，进行那种对话非常不舒服。所以这就是为什么他们选择“玩失踪”的原因。有没有办法可以超越那些不舒服的感觉，你知道，让某人知道你为什么要结束这段关系，无论是专业上，还是我的意思是，无论是友谊，还是浪漫关系。是的，嗯，我认为这归根结底是基本的同理心，你知道，真正能够跳出自己，站在对方的角度去思考。而且只是，你知道，我总是说，你知道，从你希望在那种情况下被如何对待的角度去思考，
in that situation and just extend that same courtesy to the person. So, you know, I think it's really just that extra effort that it takes to get outside of your own mind and thinking about, you know, your experience and to think about what the other person's experience is like. Is that what you would tell someone who's a chronic ghost or if they kept doing it but they wanted to change? Is that what you would advise them to do? Yes. I mean, if someone's a chronic ghoster and, you know, I think I would really want to help them maybe explore, you know, a little more deeply, kind of why they're choosing that option and why is it so hard for them to, you know, kind of confront their own emotions. You know, what makes it so difficult for them to think about having, you know, a conversation with somebody. So, you know, I certainly would encourage them to want to explore that more in depth. Are there ever instances where it is okay to ghost someone? I believe that there are.
并对那个人给予同样的礼貌。所以，你知道，我认为这真的只是跳出你自己的思维，去思考你的经历，并去思考对方的经历是什么样的，这需要额外的努力。这就是你会告诉那些慢性“玩失踪”者，如果他们一直这样做但想改变的话，你会建议他们做的事情吗？是的。我的意思是，如果有人是慢性“玩失踪”者，而且，你知道，我想我真的会想帮助他们探索，你知道，更深入一点，为什么他们选择那个选项，为什么对他们来说面对自己的情绪如此困难。你知道，是什么让他们觉得与某人进行对话如此困难。所以，你知道，我当然会鼓励他们想要更深入地探索这一点。有没有什么情况下对某人“玩失踪”是可以的？我相信有。
I actually wrote that follow-up article. That's what I'm referencing. I thought you could just dive into it. Yeah. Yeah. And I wrote that article in response to so much of the feedback that I had gotten from, you know, people who had chosen to do ghosting that there are. It does seem, you know, times especially, you know, number one, if you're in an abusive relationship, you know, physical or emotional abuse of any kind, sometimes that is in fact the safest thing to do.
我实际上写了那篇后续文章。那就是我所引用的。我以为你可以直接深入探讨它。是的。是的。我写那篇文章是为了回应我从那些选择“玩失踪”的人那里得到的很多反馈，确实有。看起来，你知道，有时，特别是，你知道，第一，如果你处于一段虐待关系中，你知道，任何形式的身体或情感虐待，有时这实际上是你能做的最安全的事情。
You know, particularly when there's physical abuse involved, leaving a relationship is in fact the most dangerous period of time for somebody who's in a physically abusive relationship. And so the best thing for them to do is to leave and to disappear and to go somewhere where that person has no way of being able to contact you. So that definitely is a scenario when I think ghosting is the best thing to do. I think that if somebody is repeatedly violating your boundaries or doing things that really make you realize that they're not all that interested in sort of how you feel or how
你知道，特别是在涉及身体虐待的情况下，离开一段关系实际上是处于身体虐待关系中的人最危险的时期。因此，他们能做的最好的事情就是离开、消失，去一个对方无法联系到你的地方。所以，这绝对是我认为“玩失踪”（ghosting）是最佳选择的情况。我认为，如果有人反复触碰你的底线，或者做出的事情让你真正意识到他们并不关心你的感受，或者
their behavior is making you feel. So for example, you know, if somebody is doing just, you know, really inappropriate things like, let's say, showing up at your job or contacting an X or, you know, just doing things or stealing from you or things. Or things. that make you feel really uncomfortable, then, you know, that, you know, really might be in a situation where you need to ghost them as well. You know, sometimes I think people think it's ghosting. If you've told the person many times that you're not interested and they're just not getting it and they're continuing to kind of sue you anyway, it's not ghosting to then cut off contact. You know, I think that sometimes you just have to do that. There are people out there that really
他们的行为让你感觉如何。举个例子，如果有人做了一些非常不恰当的事情，比如出现在你的工作场所、联系你的前任，或者做一些偷窃行为，或者让你感到非常不舒服的事情，那么，这确实可能是一种你也需要对他们“玩失踪”的情况。你知道，有时我认为人们对“玩失踪”有误解。如果你已经多次告诉对方你不感兴趣，而他们就是听不进去，依然在纠缠你，那么切断联系并不算“玩失踪”。你知道，我认为有时你必须这样做。有些人确实
don't understand and don't take the hint and don't, or not even a hint, even if you tell them directly that you're not interested. They don't listen. You know, they don't, they are just somehow, you know, ignoring your request. Then, then I think that's a time then you might have to cut off contact as well. Yeah, absolutely. It does sound like it's probably for the best in that situation. So also, as we wrap up here, I want to talk about tips you would tell people, you know, as they approach life in the modern dating world, you know, as we've talked, we've discussed this conversation. We know that the internet and online dating and apps has made dating easier, probably, you might say. It's giving people a lot of different options.
不理解，也不领会暗示，甚至即使你直接告诉他们你不感兴趣，他们也不听。他们就是以某种方式无视你的要求。那么，我认为那也是你可能不得不切断联系的时候。是的，绝对是这样。在这种情况下，这听起来确实是最好的选择。那么，在结束之前，我想谈谈你给人们的建议，关于他们如何面对现代约会世界。正如我们所讨论的，互联网、在线约会和应用程序可能让约会变得更容易了。它为人们提供了许多不同的选择。
You can find people with the same interest. It's opened up a lot of great opportunities for people to meet people special, but it's also opened up some opportunities for some more indifference and some bad behavior to take place. But what is the advice that you give to people about how to approach dating today? Yeah. So, I mean, I think it's just so hard nowadays. it's changed so much. And so number one, I'd say, you know, know your own value, that that's just incredibly important, you know, because I think it's so easy oftentimes if you've been through, you know, any number of these kind of sort of common dating scenarios like being ghosted or
你可以找到志同道合的人。它为人们结识特别的人提供了许多绝佳的机会，但也为一些冷漠和不良行为的发生创造了机会。那么，你对当今人们如何对待约会有什么建议呢？是的，我的意思是，我认为现在真的很难，一切都改变了太多。所以第一点，我会说，了解你自己的价值，这非常重要。因为我认为，如果你经历过任何数量的常见约会场景，比如被“玩失踪”或者
those other ones like called benching or stashing or all these other kind of, you know, different trends that have been out there. But, you know, it's really important to understand that, you know, you have value as a human being and to know that. And if you don't feel that you're being treated in a way where you are being valued, that it's important to be able to make that choice yourself to say, this is not acceptable to me. This behavior is not okay. I'm willing to, you know, walk away from this. So I think knowing your own personal value is just extremely important. I think, you know, being able to trust your instincts, you know, again, I don't know that there's always red flags or warning signs, but I think a lot of times you know in
其他类似的行为，比如“备胎”（benching）或“隐瞒”（stashing），以及所有这些不同的流行趋势，你很容易会感到自我怀疑。但是，了解你作为一个人的价值并认识到这一点非常重要。如果你觉得自己的价值没有得到应有的尊重，那么能够做出选择并说“这对我来说是不可接受的，这种行为是不对的，我愿意离开”是非常重要的。所以我认为了解自己的个人价值极其重要。我认为，能够相信自己的直觉，同样，我不确定是否总是有红旗信号或警告标志，但我认为很多时候你
general if someone's treating you well or not. And if you feel like there's, you know, behaviors that where it feels like, you know, oftentimes we can make excuses when we see the red flags. Almost every person I know who has ended a relationship, if you ask them, you know, were there any red flags in the beginning? They'll say yes, but I chose to ignore them. You know, I didn't listen. I assumed, you know, I thought I was being too picky or too choosy or, you know, different things. And so, you know, just really paying attention to your own emotional responses about, you know, how someone's treating you and whether you think that it's acceptable. And if they're being respectful or not, I think that's extremely important. And then I also think the other thing that's super important
大体上能感觉到对方是否在善待你。如果你觉得对方的行为让你感到不舒服，我们往往会在看到红旗信号时找借口。我认识的每一个结束一段关系的人，如果你问他们：“一开始有红旗信号吗？”他们都会说有，但我选择了忽视。我知道，我当时没听，我以为自己太挑剔了，或者其他原因。所以，真正关注你自己的情绪反应，关于对方如何对待你，以及你认为这是否可以接受，他们是否尊重你，我认为这极其重要。此外，我还认为另一件超级重要的事情是
is to really own your own role in a relationship and to really realize, that, you know, you can't just kind of swipe left or right and find that, you know, perfect relationship. That it's really, you know, anytime there are two people, there's a dynamic that's being created. And it's really important to know your own dynamic and what you bring to a relationship and to know your own beliefs, your own values, your own expectations, to know your own love language, to know everything just kind of about yourself in context of, you know, your style and approach to a relationship because it really starts to help you understand how somebody
真正承担起你在一段关系中的角色，并意识到你不能仅仅通过向左或向右滑动屏幕就找到那段完美的关系。事实上，只要有两个人在一起，就会产生一种互动。了解你自己的互动模式以及你为一段关系带来了什么，了解你自己的信仰、价值观、期望，了解你自己的爱的语言，了解关于你自己在关系风格和处理方式上的方方面面，这非常重要，因为它真的能帮助你理解某人
else is responding to you. And so I think that that's just in a very, very important part of finding a good relationship is to know, you know, just yourself very, very well and to know what you're bringing to the relationship. Absolutely. Thanks for those wonderful tips. I think that would be very helpful for people who've, you know, whether they've experienced ghosty or not, I'm sure if you haven't, you know someone who has or to prep you for the future, knowing all these tips is very helpful as we approach dating, dating friendships, and beyond. Yes, I mean, I think that these tips kind of apply to all relationships, absolutely. Well, thank you again for joining us. It's been a really interesting episode. I appreciate your time. Thank you so much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here.
是如何回应你的。所以我认为，这是找到一段良好关系中非常、非常重要的一部分，那就是非常、非常了解你自己，并知道你为这段关系带来了什么。绝对是这样。感谢这些精彩的建议。我认为这对人们非常有帮助，无论他们是否经历过“玩失踪”。我相信如果你没有经历过，你也认识经历过的人。或者为了让你为未来做好准备，了解所有这些建议在我们面对约会、友谊及其他关系时都非常有帮助。是的，我的意思是，我认为这些建议适用于所有关系，绝对是这样。好吧，再次感谢你加入我们。这是一期非常有趣的节目。感谢你的时间。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴能来到这里。
Before we go, just a reminder that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. It really helps. You can find all of our previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thank you for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在离开之前，提醒大家我们很想听到你们的声音。你可以将评论和想法发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，连在一起，点 org。请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分，这真的很有帮助。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们之前所有的《心理学谈话》节目。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的 Caitlin Luna。感谢收听。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。